the second summer update for animal
crossing is coming this week an
injustice 3 announcement may be being
teased and cuphead comes to ps4
hey guys it's been a while i'm chasity
and you've reached your safe safer
tuesday july 28th
dust off your animal crossing islands
because the second summer update is
coming on thursday and it comes with
fireworks
dreams and even backup saves i haven't
played in so long that i bet my
villagers are extremely mad at me
new horizons second summer update is
releasing on july 30th and it's adding a
few new features
one of these is the island backup
restoration service it's only available
to nintendo switch online members
the service is for backup saves but it
doesn't work the same way as typical
cloud saves on the switch
you don't need to manually back anything
up your island and villagers will
periodically update on nintendo's
servers
this way you can get your island back if
your switch is broken or stolen
nintendo also says you'll be able to
transfer your island to another switch
in a future update
the update also adds firework shows
they'll happen every sunday at 7 pm in
august
and new crafting tools will let you make
custom fireworks designs
lastly the update brings back luna when
you sleep luna can take you to dream
versions of other players islands
this will let you change things on the
island in the dream without actually
changing anything permanently on the
real island and your island will get a
dream address to share with friends
another new horizons update is coming
this fall so i'll definitely give my
friends my dream address but you guys
could also just come over and make the
island better because i just kind of
gave up on it
so a comic writer has been teasing the
return of the injustice comics but are
we also getting an injustice 3
announcement soon
injustice 3 hasn't been officially
announced but comic book writer tom
taylor has been teasing the return of
the injustice comic series on twitter he
posted the letters i and
n in the injustice font with quotes from
the first two series
so it really seems like he's teasing a
third one and just today he also tweeted
an image of the letter z
but it could also be an n turned on its
side in justice
what do you know what aren't you telling
us the previous comic series has served
as prequels to the events of the
injustice games a third series means we
could hear about a third game
unless dc decided to spin off the comics
from the games developer netherrealm has
been alternating between injustice and
mortal kombat games in the past few
years
injustice 2 was 2017 mortal kombat 11
was 2019
leaving a possible 2021 slot open for
injustice 3.
warner brothers will have announcements
at the dc fandom event on august 22nd so
we may hear more there
and finally surprise cuphead is out
today on ps4
i can't wait to get frustrated all over
again with how bad i am at that game
great game though cuphead has been
playable on pc xbox one switch and even
tesla vehicles but now ps4 players can
finally play
you can grab it for 20 us dollars or 16
euros or 16 pounds
a special update is also on the way to
the xbox one version of the game
it will add a digital art gallery behind
the scenes commentary and a soundtrack
but there's no date on that update yet
developer studio mdhr is also still
working on the cuphead dlc the delicious
last course
it adds more levels and bosses plus miss
chalice as a new playable character
there's still no date on that and the
last we heard it was still planned for
2020
studio mdhr will have more to say in the
coming months
and just a reminder that we're still
raising money for charity with the
gamespot store
head over to store.gamespot.com to buy
cool play for all merch for yourself or
your friends including face masks
t-shirts hoodies and this awesome
skateboard
all proceeds go to charity until the end
of august so head to the store
get something cool and help us raise
money for a good cause
and that's your save save for tuesday
i'm chastity and you can find me on
twitter at chastity underscore v
and hey if you missed out on comic con
and you want to catch up on all the
latest on the boys
star trek rick and morty and more head
over to gamespot universe and i'll see
you next time
[Music]